do you still I know your writing I know
you're getting your PhD you're doing
this dissertation you've got all the
stuff going on and music and writing and
six albums I'm exhausted here and you
talk can I just yeah but do you still
honestly want to act
oh
or does it have to be something I mean
how honest do we want to get honestly
look it's Honest Abe time
here's the reality
you know
you've done it you've you're almost 60
you said yes isn't that great if I say
it it freaks me out a little like it
really is like how about you're older
than 50. you're almost older than 50.
I'm a woman of a certain age and
You've Done big movies and you've done
big TV and you've you've written and
you've played music and you have a great
marriage you have children a daughter
daughter Anna and you have all this you
know
you've lived your life and you still
have many years to go yeah but at this
point do you just say I want to do what
inspires me what fulfills me what makes
me I don't know Happy's kind of but I
guess makes me happy but a sense of um
do something that has a sense of uh play
enjoyment I mean you know because I am
I'm so steeped in myth and depth
psychology that that's not a light
question for me that's probably like the
most profound question you could ask me
and what I would say is
if you have the Good Fortune to feel a
vocation or a calling towards something
if something is pulling you and you get
animated by something you are very very
lucky that's good fortune
and for others and myself included like
the happiest time of my life ever has
been being in graduate school like isn't
that there's no question I've had so
much joy acting and certainly my
marriage Rob Watsky he's such an
incredible partner he teaches improv and
he has this non-profit we do these great
shows that at you can look him up at
turbine Arts
okay he's gonna be so mad turbine
dasharts.org there's a dash and if they
want to take an improv class they can go
there Monday oh yeah Monday's gone and
he's incredible he's an incredible
teacher but anyway those have all been
great Joys being in relation to other
people but the thing of the like the
soul work what is your that is like
that's the 64 000 question and some
people might end up just being being of
service to others and living you know
it's different for everybody for me it
was about this this thing of of
education and specifically learning
about myth and James Hillman's writings
Young's writings you know the just
that's been the joy so I don't know what
it leads to after this but
yeah you know um I don't know it'd be
great if like you could have a
mythologist you know I need to call my
mythologist the way you might call your
shrink you would be like
would the mid person say about this you
know it's funny because even though
you're talking about something in which
a lot of people probably don't know a
ton about you've studied this spent
endless hours learning and educating
yourself and doing this I think
the under the message
of of anything we do really is is
ultimately
doing things for yourself doing things
it's not doing things for yourself it's
but not doing things just to please
people not doing things just to like we
talked about earlier but doing things
that you feel whole that make you feel
complete James Hillman who is very
present in my dissertation who's opposed
to jungian and has written incredible
books revisioning psychology is one of
the big ones but he would say you move
towards something if it animates your
life
and if you're doing something for other
people all the time you're gonna feel
there's a deficit that you're
something's out of sync I I've said this
before sometimes because we have lived
so much as actors where we are pleasing
or trying to get it right or hit the
mark or say the line and that is so much
about it can be so much about what
someone else needs from us what the time
is what the director needs what the
writers need we got to get it in on time
but the the thing of uh I sometimes will
do like no one's looking very pretend
there's nobody around like
right now
what would you like to do right now just
very quietly on the shoulder like what
and it'd be like I think
I would like to do this for a little
while I'm learning to like fan that fire
of
what would be if what would be helpful
right now in this moment